spider warren spider-worn radioactive spider-worn
it's been a while since we covered a cosmic wonder
video warren i'm gonna text you telling you i hate
your video anyway um did you just call me oh damn
all right we're gonna watch today we're causing
wonder spider-man 4 and the amazing spider-man 3
update gonna be enjoying this video if you leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated anyhow
so today's report is coming from daniel rbk i'm
sure if you kept up with spider-man knowing home
all of the leaks all the rumors everything
that was going around you know who he is and
he did a video on his youtube channel recently
talking about everything that he's heard so far
about andrew garfield and toby mcguire returning
for future spider-man projects in fact the title
of his video was spider-man future projects with
andrew garfield now he starts off by saying that
that's conclusive marvel studios and sony found
massive success with spider-man no way home and
the other two spider-man returning and due to the
success they are obviously open to them returning
for future spider-man projects but daniel rpk
specifically states that what he has heard coming
straight from him is that toby and andrew will
indeed return toby and andrew seem more than happy
to come back for spider-man no way home and in
some of the behind-the-scenes videos and interview
videos toby even said he's kind of up for anything
so this doesn't come as that big of a surprise
it's just kind of crazy to you know pause and
think about the fact of how we didn't even know if
this was really going to happen if this was like
just a possibility on the horizon and the fact
that we will probably more than likely get more
projects with them now which makes me wonder how
this one movie like we saw how avengers
change cinema and i'm wondering how
this precedent could change cinema moving
forward too as well it's gonna be gnarly
to see and the fact that we have like toby and
andrew back which both seem like they ended with
not the best of terms and now they seem so
enthused yeah and even sam raimi was like it'd
be beautiful to do another spider-man or something
like that which i feel like you know everyone's
vibes especially off of the way everyone left
off have way improved so daniel goes on to
state that something is in the works right now
something with either andrew or toby or perhaps
even both now he says that it's not concrete
at this point meaning he doesn't really know
what it's going to be he says he doesn't know
if it's going to be a quick little cameo and
perhaps the multiverse so maybe a cameo in
multiverse of madness like we've been hearing
for some time now although we haven't really
heard much about toby in multiversal madness
recently he still very well could appear in
the film so daniel says it could be a quick
cameo in a multiverse movie or another movie
or it could be a full blown out spider-man 4
or tasm 3. and obviously i think this is so all
possibilities they would want another full movie
with andrew garfield with toby maguire or perhaps
both of them or even bring tom holland back as
well and the three of them be in a movie together
why doesn't sony just do a movie called spider-man
i know perfect a whole movie with just the three
of them i think that would just be incredibly
special who have to fight a really just crazy
villain and also learn a lot about themselves
nah i just want quips they should fight michael
morbius fight michael morbius that's all i want
green light morbius two you cowards we did hear
a rumor not too long ago that was talking about
maybe a movie with andrew garfield and toby just
the two of them together going kind of across the
multiverse i don't know if there's any legitimacy
to that rumor at all but that is actually a movie
that i really wouldn't mind seeing i think it
would be pretty funny and pretty cool here's the
thing i would only want a crossover movie with
them again if marvel is working with them on it
that's why i'm not excited for like the idea of a
toby and andrew film because as cool as it sounds
in theory like i don't feel like if they're not
working with marvel on this it would be that good
yeah absolutely and two i don't know i feel like
it would actually feel the most complete if they
had all three of them because of that brotherly
bond i almost feel like with two of them it would
be cool but it would also feel like something's a
little missing but right now it looks like we have
a few different options of what could happen
with toby and andrew and it does seem like they
are returning sony wants it plus andrew and toby
probably want it as well in fact andrew garfield
was recently asked about the amazing spider-man 3
and if it was going to be made and this is what he
said no update from me no one's going to believe
me anything i say ever again and that's my problem
and that's true he went around for i think way
to take responsibility for talking about how he
wasn't the werewolf and he's not in spider-man
knowing home and then of course he was and of
course that's not his fault no one blames him for
that that's what he had to do but let's just put
it this way if tasm 3 is going to be made he's
definitely not going to be the one that's going
to tell us it's being made but check out this
very interesting i mean this is coming from
morbius director daniel espinoza and it's about
the post post-credit scenes in morbius and i won't
really spoil anything but let's just say it's
heavily implied that spider-man has a future in
sony's spider-man universe i recently said that
thanks to the post-credits scenes for morbius
i'm not really sure that sony has any type of plan
for spider-man i think they might have an idea of
what they want to do but they're kind of just
winging it right now however it appears right
off of what daniel espinoza said that maybe they
do here's what he said i think that the future
is very exciting and i think that the plans that
sony has in very closed rooms that i'm not really
allowed to attend or the small snippets i've heard
fills me with joy but if i said anything they
would shoot me on the spot so this actually sounds
pretty decent he says that sony has a very very
tight team working on the future of the spider
heading out well teams are tight he's not allowed
in that closed door he's not allowed to hear what
that team is working on even though he just worked
on a film that exists in the spider-man universe
so i'm starting to think that maybe just morbius
unfortunately had to suffer with big changes made
to it because of the delay it was delayed over
two years and a lot happened in those two years
including spider-man no way home so sony's plans
probably changed and stuff got cut from morbius
and the film kinda just took a hit unfortunately
i'm not gonna lie after morbius my hopes for tasm
three really went down not the fact that like it
needs to get made it got me worried about how sony
would handle it i really wanted it i i still do
ultimately i think it would be really cool
to have however when it comes to like venom
let there be cartage and morbius uh you know
i i don't want a 1003 where i walk out going
it's fine i wish that we didn't do that actually
yeah and i mean even though they're perfectly
capable of finding quality directors to make these
things in sony's hands alone i am much more wary
of what they would decide to do because i
just don't know if it's gonna get the time
love and attention that it would need to really
be everything we want it to be the good news is
is that it does look like sony has somewhat of a
plan and they're being very secretive about that
which is good and also pretty expected especially
after spider-man no way home i mean we all knew
about toby and andrew being in the film basically
two years before it came out so the fact that
daniel espinoza the director of morbius a movie
in their spider-man universe wasn't allowed in
this tiny closed door this tiny room of people
who knows what the future has in store for the
spider verse means that they really are trying
to do everything they can to keep everything a
secret even though we are hearing that toby
that doesn't mean it's a good plan though
maybe they just kept him out cause he directed
morbius however i do think i would like
some type of confirmation that spider-man 4 is
going to be made or the amazing spider-man 3 is
going to be made i don't need to know the entire
movie i just would like a confirmation that it's
going to happen and it looks like i don't want to
know till release day according to daniel richmond
sony is talking about that right now they have
things in plan and hopefully this secret plan
that sony has for their spider-man universe
will be revealed soon but let me know what
you think about all of this news in the comments
down below and would you choose a spider-man 4
movie with tobey maguire or would you choose a the
amazing spider-man 3 movie with andrew garfield if
you had to choose one i'll probably ultimately
choose the amazing spider-man 3 so we can close
out that chapter all right guys well what do you
want spider-man 4 or amazing spider-man 3. leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell leave a like and we'll catch you guys soon